[音楽]
[拍手]
聞こえますでしょうか
はいみなさんこんにちは明治大付の砂田です
今は紹介いただきましたけれどもあの
数学者です
まあ今日はですね私の研究とそれから数学についてね数学というのはどういう方なのか
という事まあ皆さんに
理解していただきたいために
いただきます
先ほどビデオでですね
なんか変な数学者出てきましたよねあの
練習率を
3君14159魅力と覚えなんか全部覚えているというような
まああの数学者というとちょっと変わった人
前によって朴念仁さらにオタクだとかね
まあいろいろなその悪口というのか
まあ中に褒め言葉だったと思ってオタクだと言う
うちの学長もいるんですけどもいい
それはそれとしてまああの数学というのはですねああいうものではないです
まあ私は円周率50桁ぐらいので暗記できますけれどもそれだからといって数学者では
ないそれだけで数学者じゃないんですね
3.1415926のその数の
並び方とか
そういうことの法則をまあ見いだそうとそういうことをやり始めると数学者になると
いう
ことですまあそれであの
最初にあのーちょっと
あのこれがまあ今日お話しすることなんですけども発明家発見かと言う
んですけれども
数学は新しい結果を得た年
したらですねそれ発見したのか発明したのかという
そういうことをちょっと考えてみようというわけです
それでこのことについてはですねまあいろいろ様々な数学者の中でもいろいろな考え方
があって
まず一番左のハーディというイギリスの数学者ですけども
この人は数学的概念数学的な実在馬手間かかるリアリティと言いますけどそういうのは
我々の外にあって
その数学者はそれを発見しそしてそれを観察しそしてそれを論文にまとめるというそう
いうものであるとですから発見ということを持った
持っているわけですで真ん中のブラブローウェルという人この人はおらんから数学者
ですけども
この人はですねつぎのように
ています
あの数学的な実在なんてものはないんだと
それは数がっあの人間の営みがその精神的な営みが作り上げるもので
人間がいなければ数学はないだろうと
そういうこと言ってますすなわち
数学は発明だと言う
まあ実は素ですね
まあそういうことでまぁいろんな考え方があるんですけども私の答えは一番最後に
与えるとして数学と言ったらどういうものかただ数学てなかなかはね説明するのが
難しい
まあさっきのパイの音の話ではないですけれども
あんなことでないからお茶を濁してしまう可能性もあるけどます
というのもあのベーユと一番右側にあの写真が載ってますけども
この1話皆さんしモールで言ってことにんですかね
大変有名なあの
別学者ですけれどもそのお兄さんです
この人はですねつぎのようなこと言ってます
数学は数学者しか理解できないという特徴を持っていると
これはもう明らかにあるですよねもうあの
何だろうから突き放したような言い方ですよね
まあそれじゃあちょっと困るので少し
あの
なってるからあの私が数学をやってて思うことをちょっと話をしてみたいと思います
あの数学の話とよりをむしろちょっとそれでこじつけたような話なんですけども
中島8という小説家がいますけれどもこの人がですね名人伝という短編を書いています
これは中国の故事にを抉ってのからまあ逸話を
にまあ託してですねまあ弓の名人になろうとしていくか
1まあその人についてちょっと書いてるなかなか面白い短編なんですけれどもこの指の
名人だろうとしてたあの男はですねあの
まあ師匠について
修行を始めるんだけども師匠次のようなアドバイスをしました
それの木したいですね伊藤ツールしその糸の先にのみ
小さいの日です
書かれるとちょっと可愛くなるのみですそれをつけて特価眺めロト
それがだんだん大きくなってきたらあなたは進歩してるんだと言う
ことなのでその男はですね毎日毎日それを眺めしたという
あの最後はですねその身が馬のように見え
さらにす馬自身は今度は山のように見えたと
そういうことでまぁ
弾丸だんだんとまぁ進歩したということなんですけどもまぁそのオーチーもあるんです
けどそれはちょっと読んでいただいて
あのなかなか面白いオチなのでにょんでいただければいいと思うんだけども
数学をやってるとですね
まあ数学的な概念というものを我々は構築していくんだけども
最初はものすごく曖昧なものが頭の中に浮かぶんですねそれがあのずーっと考えている
と
だんだん見えてくるもちろんのみの表に見えてくるわけじゃなくてねさっきの話で具体
的に見えてくるわけじゃないんだけども
だんだん概念が固まってきて最後はまあ正しいと思えるような概念に達するというわけ
です
a たあのそれからもう一つあのついでに言っておきますけども数学というのはあの
論理
理詰めであのものを考える学問だと考えそう思う人もいるんですけどそれは誤解であっ
て
最後はですねロングにまとめるときは論理であの
突き進みますけれどもその途中の段階がなく新しいものを考えている段階の時は
美意識です
芸術的なと言ってもいいぐらいの美意識
があの非常に重要な役割を果たします
3色といえばですね実は歳あの
現代に通じる数学まあこれはバビロニアから始まっていますけれども
現在に2集数学としては古代ギリシャから始まったと言われていますけれども
北村すという人この人あの三平方の定理で念願
だよ
有名な哲学者で終わり数学者でもある人ですけれどもこの人がですね
あの自分が住んでたあの
南イタリアのプロトンというところの近くで取れる
黄鉄鉱というねこういうのも見てですね
正多面体という概念を考え出しました
これ見ると情報じゃあお茶してますけれどもこの中でより美しい多面体が見えてくると
いう
ことに気がついてじゃあそれはいったいどういうふうに特徴付けたらいいのかどういう
概念として
あの考えればいいのかということを考えて正多面体というが慰霊を
考え出した
その後ですねて相手とすというソクラテスのあの
お手したんですけどもその人が実は正多面体ってのはご主人しかないということを生涯
しました
一番左が
制作費あり一番右が生理中明太というちょっと複雑 here やっぱり美意識
美しいモノマーピタゴラス美しいと思ったんですよねあの日あの性多面たよ
だからそういうところから始まっているということです
決勝が出てきましたまあ普通は決勝はこんなねあの塊ですけれども
ここではですねちょっとダイヤモンド結晶についてちょっとお話をしたいと思います
これが私の研究に関係があるのでで左はもちろんこれはね皆さん方と一に宝石としての
第8問です
とです右はそれのミクロな構造を荒らしているいわゆる
ダイヤモンドの結晶構造というもので
これもご存知だと思うけど炭素から炭素の実からなっている
決勝ですで丸いところボールの所へ行くか嘘があってあと某がねあの
ありますけれどもそれは炭素同士があのいわゆる共有結合という力を出し合ってそれで
結びついているというような
まあこの形を見てですね
何か特別なことがあるのだろうかとまあ考え始めるまあそれが私のあのひとつの動機
だったんですけども
まず簡単なあのことが2つ分かります見た目でだいたいわかるということなんですけど
まぁこれがあのキットで作った
ダイヤモンド結晶の構造が
んですけどもじっと眺めているとそうするとさっき出てきた製三角正四面体が
見えてきます正四面体を積み重ねるとあのこういう結晶ダイヤモンド結晶ができると
いうことにまず気がつきます
第それはまだ目に見えてるね段階ですけども
てもうちょっと詳しく見るの
くださいん
んでいた
ません
動かなくなりました
おっ
ただごめんなさいそっち鵜飼は良いですねなんかそこに人が隠れておりますけれども
いい
その人の頭を向けていますが8で大門の継承何が再来特別だろうか
でそれはですねあの最初は分からなかった見ただけでは
だけどじーっと眺めているだけじゃなくてさらにいろいろ数学的にいじってみるとじつ
は今日等方性強いと縫製という性質を持つことがわかっ
てきましたこの段階はさっきのの右側ですね
馬に見えてくるそういうような段階です
今日東方設定に一体何かというとダイヤモンド結晶の中から勝手にですね2つ
原子を選びます
そうその元首にはですね棒が4つ付いています
それぞれ4つついているとでそのボールのところにある1から4まで勝手にランダムに
番号を付けてしまいます
でもう一方のねもう一つ選んでもう一方も同じようにランダム日から4まで
棒に名前を付けてしまいますそうするとですね
8この結晶構造を保ちながら
平行移動回転それから折り返しでこの左側にある部分を右側にある部分にしかも番号も
ちゃんと重なるように打つことができると言う
いうことがわかりますこれは非常に強い性質なんですけどもまぁというかそういうこと
がわかってきました
例えば今日等方性という概念をだから言い出したというわけです
そうするとやっぱりいったあのさっきのピタゴラスからて愛って鳥栖というね
流れを考えるとあの体てぃとぅんあぴっぴらぱらスター正多面体という概念を見出した
んだけども
今度はじゃあいくつ正多面体があるかを考えたのがて入って pos でそれで5種類
あっっていうことに
まあ気がついた
ですがこの場合6じゃあ今日等方性を持つ
他の結晶構造は何かとそう考えは自然ですよね
ページ答えはですね実はただ一つ
もう一つだ課題問題外では誰だもう1
もう一つだけあるということに気がつきました
ん
まと読みでダイヤモンドの双子と私は呼んでますが
数学的とつけた理由はこれはの現実の決勝ではないですね
あの
数学的な結晶ということでまぁ
服装に名前を付けます
付けましたこれもよく見るとですねまあ自分できっと作ったんですけども模型を作った
んですけどもじーっと眺めていると
810個の原子が乗っかっているあのう
お店減ってきのから入れます
これ私の娘が作ってくれた誕生日のプレゼントです
大変素晴らしい娘てない覚悟であの
自慢して星も2位ですがこういうものです
でじっと眺めてみるとあのさっき見かけましたけど10個のあの
原子が乗っかっている輪っかがあっちこっちに見えます
むしろ10個の輪っかで出来上がっていると言ってもいい
それが10位印鑑と言います
宴は具体的にお見せするとごく一部ですけども10印鑑はこんな格好をしています
こういうものが組み合わさってできているということがわかります
さらにあの面白いのはですねまたこれをじっと眺めて一つの結果の原子のところ
着目してそれを含む者 x 印かんだ10個のあの元首が乗っかってる輪っかいくつ
あるかってを数えてみるとじつは15個ありました
これ数えの大変だったんですけども here の本当にそんな15もあるのかと最初
びっくりしたんですけどもええ
これ全部リストアップしたものです
あのダイヤモンドの場合はですねこの場合はあの数えてみると
6員環からなってますけども6員環が一つの芸所登録印鑑の数は12個です
これ見どもまた12校かどうかというのはから五味塚あの
見極めの難しいんですけどまぁというかそういうことにま
ていましたんですが15個もあるってのちょっと驚きですね
またこういう性質を持つあの数学的な
可能モデルをモデルっていうかな結晶構造を
発見したんですけれども実はこれ研究の副産物です
これを目的としてたわけではないです私は離散幾何解析学というね
あの数だけの一分野を研究しているものでこれは
広くネットワークあの継承構図もネットワークですけども後産業システムネットワーク
それから google
検索エンジがあります検索エンジもね実はネットワークです
けどもまぁそういう色々なネットワークは統一的に研究するということで遺産幾何解析
学を正
専門としていますでその副産物として
このダイヤモンドの2具を
発見したということ
さあそれでまあ時間もそろそろないので最初に提示した
発明家発見かということについてちょっと私の考えを述べてみたいと思います
またちょっと人の踏めあのふんどしを買い頭いいことを社会ですけども
あの夏目漱石の夢中ばと言う
話があるんですけどもそれはなつみ礎石が真の夢を見てそう
夢を正
小説にしたもの
ものですけれどもその中に運慶というねあの短編がはいあります
文系っていうのはあの東大寺の南大門
店家の
金剛力士像いわゆる三大像をぬ振ったという事で有名な人ですけどもまぁこのうん江原
女性キャ
びっくりしたのはですねもうあのなんでもない普通の木からですね
鑿と槌だけで降り出していくという
を見ています
しかもに様というやめてね迫力のあるものをどうやってあのう
そういうちょ掘り出すことができるのかという
ことを言って呟いてから隣にいた人がですねうん k は尿の姿を刻んでいるのでは
なくすでに機の中に埋まっている尿を開放しているのかと
そうあの
隣の人がつぶやいたとそういう話です
この話をですね私読んだときまさに自分が数学をやっているとそんな気がすすなわちも
埋まってるんだとどっかり
金中で待ってませんよ数学はねだけども何かしらあの
埋まってるものだから外から見えないんだけどもそれはないか
開放していると
掘り出している凝りだしてるっていうか自由にしているという感じがやっぱりします
こういう言い方はやはりこれは発明というよりはや発見という感じがするんですよね
木の中にあるものを発見しているという感じがするので私の答えは
まあ
犬である従ってさっきのハーディの言葉なんですけど数学的自在は我々の外に存在し
数学者の仕事はそれを発見観察しそれを書き留めることであるというのが私も賛成を
する
ことです
米最後ですけども
まあもし興味を待つ持たれた方はおそらくいいなぁいらっしゃらないと思いますが
あのーダイヤモンドはなぜ美しいという本をちょっとご覧いただくと少しそんなことが
書いてありますのでぜひご覧ください
11秒前ですどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]